i just want to clear up some uh
confusion that might have happened
because of of
one of the problems in the last video
and actually it's a good chance to
understand things a little bit more
deeply so one of the problems that in
the last video was this and this was
sent to me by a viewer and it was the
integral the definite integral from i
think it was e to the x to e to the
fourth
of and then they had a dx on top over x
times the square root of ln
x
and another viewer pointed out something
and and it's actually a really good
point that
right here i mean i i did this
mechanically and you know to some degree
i got the right answer where i just took
the antiderivative of this using u
substitution unwound the u substitution
and then evaluated kind of the
anti-derivative at this point and at
this point but one thing to to realize
you know this right here this is a
shorthand for
this
the limits of integration we want to
take essentially the area under the
curve from
x
equals e to the x to x equals sorry x
equals e to the fourth of this thing
right here
and now all of a sudden when you look at
it this way keeping the lim having the
same variable and the limits of
integration as you do in the actual
integral of itself or what you're taking
the area under the curve of it doesn't
make a lot of sense you can't have x
equal e to the x i mean you could have
some type of i don't know iterative
formula or something but this is a
little bit
this this isn't um this isn't good i
guess it's the best way to do it so if
it a correct way to construct this
problem it should have been written
something like this let me do another
color
green for correct so this problem should
have been written something like y is
equal to
the integral from
e to the x
to e to the fourth of instead of using x
it could use any other variable like
let's say t
of dt
over
t times the square root of the natural
log of t and now you don't run this
problem because you're running from the
the the function that you're taking the
integral of is defined in terms of t so
your and then the boundaries are t is
equal e to the x to t
is equal to e to the fourth and now you
don't run into this kind of weird
defining a variable in terms of itself
and and you know that to some degree
that's that's not appropriate
so that's one point and and the other
point i want and this was all pointed
out by i think his name is uh i don't
know if it's if it it i'm assuming it's
a he uh cognito ego sum who uh who
pointed this out and it was a good thing
to point out and
this is i mean you know this is how the
problem should have been written and the
other thing that he pointed out was
you know when do you do the the you know
i do use substitution in this example in
the last video and then i don't change
the limits of integration but what i did
do is i just unwound it so let me show
you the example i just want to clarify
this confusion and show you that you
could do it either way so let's do this
integral right here so the last time you
watch the last video if you want the
details on this but we said
u
is equal to
the natural log
of t
and then d u
dt is going to be equal to 1 over t
or
d u is equal to 1 over
t
dt just multiplied both sides of this by
dt
and so if we look at that if i rewrite
this integral up here let me do it down
here
it could be rewritten as
excuse me
y is equal to the integral from and i
want to be careful i want to write t is
equal to e to the x
2t is equal to e to the fourth
of
what was it it was
the
natural log of x was under the square
root sign and that's in the denominator
let me just write that as
the natural log
of t sorry not natural log of x natural
log of t to the minus one half
times one over t
dt all i did is i rewrote
this right here
right i just said this is the same the
square root in the denominator that's
just natural log of t to the minus one
half times one over t right this is same
thing as one over t and then you can put
the dt out here right you're just
multiplying them all and so i just
rewrote the equation right there like
this and now if we do the u the u
substitution this right here
is our u we said u is equal to natural
log of t
made that definition right there
and then d u is sitting right here
so you get this is d u and the way i
knew that and you should re-watch that
video if you found this confusing so i'm
going a little faster because i just
want to clarify some of the confusion
that might be around kind of unwinding
the the substitution but the way that i
knew to do that is you have a function
and you have its derivative sitting
right here so that's what tells you that
this should be what u is equal to
but anyway if you make the substitution
and this is key you get y is equal to
the integral
from t
is equal to e to the x to t
is equal to e to the fourth and we did
our u substitution u to the minus one
half
d u
and now there's two ways that you could
you could think about this integral from
here you could just continue to take the
antiderivative of this and then unwind
the substitution and that's what i did
in the last video so i'll do that first
and then the other option is to just
change the limits of integration and and
essentially stay in the u world so let's
do it the first way so this is a pretty
easy integral to
solve the the anti-derivative of u to
the minus one-half we increase this
exponent by one so that you get u
u to the
one half sorry not
not minus one half u to the one half and
then you divide by that number which is
the same thing as dividing by one half
the same thing as multiplying by two and
you can if you take the derivative of
this it should come out to that one half
times two is one
lower this by one you get minus one half
and then you wanna evaluate that from t
is equal to e to the x 2t is equal to e
to the fourth
well you don't have a t sitting here so
what you want to do is unwind
unwind the substitution so this is the
same thing as
2 what was u equal to u we defined it as
the natural log of t
so it's 2 times
the natural log of t
to the one half
evaluated from t is equal to e to the x
to t is equal to e to the fourth and
this is what i did in the last video now
equally legitimate thing to do is you
could have actually redefined
the boundaries
here in terms of u so let me do that
i'll do that in
in purple i don't want to lose this up
here so we could have said we know that
u is equal to the natural log of t
right we know that
u
is equal to the natural log of t that
was our substitution so when t is equal
to e to the x what is u equal to
so u would be equal to the natural log
when t is equal to e to the x
e to the x well that's just equal to x
so this boundary so we could rewrite the
integral as y is equal to the integral
when t is equal to e to the x u is equal
to x
and when t is equal to
e to the fourth what is u equal to
well u is equal to the natural log of
whatever t is so when t is e to the
fourth the natural log of e to the
fourth is four what power do we have to
raise e to to get
e to the fourth we have to raise to the
fourth power so it's the integral from x
to four
of
u to the minus one half d u
and now these boundaries are from u is
equal to x to u is equal to four and
this is a really important thing to
realize and you know not think about it
mechanically and and that's why i
appreciate uh i'll call him cognito for
short i appreciate his comment because
it does it you know it does
make you appreciate that you what what
the boundaries really you know what
variable they really are being defined
in and now this we can just do it the
same way this is equal y is equal to the
anti-derivative which is just 2u
to the one-half
and now we just evaluate from x
from sorry from u is equal to x
people seldom write u is equal to x but
it's good when you're doing substitution
two u is equal to four
and then that is equal to
two
x to the one half
minus
two times four to the one half
two times four to the one-half
which is oh sorry no i'm i always switch
you have to do the the upper boundary
first so this is
two
times four to the one-half
minus
two times x to the one half and that's
you know you could watch my videos on
that but that's if you're taking a you
know why do you do the upper boundary
first if this is the function
and these are the two boundaries in this
case this would be four and this is x
so when you take the integral to four
you're kind of getting everything up up
to
that point and then you subtract out
everything up to this point because what
you want to be left with
is everything
right there and that's why you do that
so then this is let's see four to the
one half this is 2
two times two is four minus two x to the
one half anyway i appreciate
cognito's uh comment there and hopefully
that clears up clears up a little bit
about indefinite integration oh about
definite integration using
u-substitution and i want to point out
it doesn't matter what order you go in
and it really they they end up
essentially doing the same thing just at
slightly different stages in when you're
evaluating the problem